[Music]  mom dad hey Google what's in my calendar  today you have one event called house to  yourself yeah Google and aftershave to  my shopping list good whoo  you want me to clean these sheets later  okay I'll remind you a change will be  animal okay Google turn down the  temperature two degrees hey Google begin  operation Kevin operation Kevin underway  [Music]  better get out before somebody sees us  Oh  [Music]  turn down the temperature [ __ ] this your  tree fell it was interesting going back  in doing a lot of this stuff it did a  very good job on the set decoration and  the props and all the shots were really  spot-on I'm hoping that people are  really gonna have to dig it that's nuts  [Music]  with buddy box it'll wrap Christmas tree  fitty cast  high-five  [Music]  I got kids  [Music]